we get started just because we're 200
people might be signing online I can
this to tux hopefully in this session so
be terrific we'll start with the first
one and tell us about the quasi gradient
methods so thank you very much for
inviting me it's always a pleasure to be
back at the Simon's Institute I'll speak
about something which is mainly about
optimization and it's about optimization
motivated by machine learning problems
by training machine learning models but
there'll be a fair amount of randomized
miquelina algebra behind this particular
algorithm so the title is stochastic
wise our gradient methods by quasi
gradient methods I mean imagine quasi
Newton methods quasi Newton methods what
I try to do they try to approximate
Newton step in a cheap way so that you
look at the Hessian and you do a certain
operation with the Hessian and you don't
want to invert the Hessian exactly so
you do some some tricky step and an
approximation you call this a quasi
Newton approximation so we do the same
thing also with the matrix but not not
with the Hessian but with the Jacobian
so in fact the step can be seen as a
very similar step to - what a Newton
methods do but with a Jacobian this our
garden will be very introduced so those
of you who know what that means it's
it's another point of view at variance
reduction in stochastic optimization if
you haven't seen this out I'll talk
about it anyway ok so this is the paper
this is joint work with Robert Gower and
and passes buck right so the outline
first I introduced the problem the
stochastic optimization problem which is
an empirical risk minimization problem
and then the second part I'll talk about
Jacobian sketching so this is the part
where the randomized numerical algebra
step comes in and this is one way of
looking at how we develop the algorithm
the algorithm called jack sketch this
control stochastic reformulations part
is a completely equivalent way to
develop and understand the same
algorithm
but from a different perspective and
then I'll do a comparison of Jax
catching some special cases of Jax case
such as saga and and and show that in
fact we can improve on some of the best
known bonds for for saga and result some
conjectures as well while giving a
generic overarching approach to variance
reduction okay so so here's the problem
the problem is minimize average of a
huge number of functions these are loss
functions and each function has to do
with with one data point and a label but
I will track from this for instance you
can have L to regularize least squares
then the loss function to be like this
so there's the I it label I take the
point and here everything is is linear
so there's a linear predictor I will
assume in fact throughout the whole talk
that all these functions are convex in
fact strong you have strong convexity
for the entire function f now many of
these ideas can be extended I believe
they can be extended to just weakly
convex functions non convex functions
and so on but there's many new ideas
behind this I want to analyze this the
simplest possible case of this problem
here another problem would be L to
regular holistic regressions just these
are the kinds of problems we're looking
at alright so the basic workhorse for
empirical risk minimization is gradient
descent or variations of gradient sent
where you replace the gradient by
something else and usually he replaces
by an unbiased estimator of the gradient
in some way or another and there's many
ways of doing this the simplest way of
doing that is is simply go back here and
sample one are uniformly at random
there's already written as discrete
expectation with uniform probabilities
over these I and data points so in fact
you can just sample are uniformly random
take gradient of one function at I and
by doing that you get an unbiased
estimator of the grade this is not
necessarily very good because the
variance of this estimator will not
diminish throughout the Ituri process
you get a slow algorithm so the whole
point here is to accelerate on that so
if you look at the variance of this
estimator of course it matters if you
use gradient
send the variance zero this
deterministic algorithm is good there's
no variance to speak off but then you
have to compute the grading and that's
that's the problem because if n data
points and could be billions so you have
to take a pass through the entire data
set compute gradient of every single
function here okay and you want to avoid
it
so that's the whole point don't do that
don't take a pass over the data set SGD
which I already described sample one are
uniform and random then there will be
unbiased estimator of the gradient but
the variance is big and you don't have
really control over it and it doesn't
even diminish to zero when you're at the
optimum so in fact when you start the
iterative process at the optimum it will
just drive your ways unstable algorithm
the way to kill the variance is to push
the step sizes to zero but then this
slows down everything so the idea is
what to do about this okay
so graphically this looks something like
this okay GD H GD goes in these strange
directions these are the stochastic
gradient of these individual functions
there's no reason why they should point
downwards but on average they would and
you eventually get there and the trade
of this these are very very expensive
steps but they are form a nice smooth
curve these are very cheap steps you
have to take many more of them okay now
there's several approaches to variance
reduction that I know of the simplest
one is just kill the variance through
step sizes just take step sizes which go
down to zero and in this way of course
you killed that the variance but of
course the con of this is that this
slows down the algorithm and this is
what we want to avoid now another way is
mini batching of course the extreme is
that you mini batch you compute a great
full gradient okay there's a full pull
mini batch then you kill the variance
completely but then you pay for it
because you have to do the work you have
to compute the gradient of all of those
elements in the mini batch so that's
that's the problem with that so we want
to avoid that
another approach would be important
sampling so maybe don't select one I
uniformly random maybe some non-uniform
probabilities would actually lead to
lower variance this is yet another
approach so what we'll do here we'll
combine some of these approaches will
combine this this and there as well and
don't land
we'll know to work with decreasing step
sizes adjusting the direction is the
most significant approach which started
about 2012 with the s AG method I don't
have it here suck stochastic average
gradient recently that work won the the
Lagrange process in continuous
optimization this summer and all of this
work is simply some some some follow-up
very interesting algorithms motivated by
this achieving the same or very similar
results but through very different
approaches SDC a stochastic dual core is
Sandor SVR G stochastic their variance
reduce to greatness and and so on okay
so now we're introducing a new approach
to variance reduction and this new
approach is motivated through randomized
incremental in algebra we call it
Jacobian sketching and the algorithm
called Jack's sketch so this is the idea
so first we lift the problem and then we
sketch what do I mean by this so we
generate a function where all of these
little functions f1 through FN will be
put into into a vector so this is a
Multi multi variate function so we live
the problem from one dimension to n
dimensions we form the Jacobian of this
mapping actually this is the transpose
of it but anyway I just call this the
Jacobian so all the gradients are in the
columns so we lifted everything and now
we look at this Jacobian and we just
think about it for a while so what is
the first observation you might have the
first observation would be well if I
multiply this by the I to net basis
vector so everywhere 0 is just 1 in in
the eigth place then you get the
stochastic gradient that SGD uses and
the SGD picks i uniformly random okay so
that's an observation another
observation is well if you multiply it
by the vector of all ones divided by n
you get a gradient ok so somehow of
course this Jacobian contains
information which is useful for the
estimation of the gradient and now this
has zero variance this is large possibly
large variance who doesn't diminish what
else can we do so the idea of Jacobian
sketching is to
maintain a sequence of these jacobians
estimates of these jacobians without
actually computing them will estimate
them and we will do sketches of the
Jacobian which are cheap so we'll
multiply the two Jacobian from the right
by a random matrix and this information
will be used to update our estimate of
the Jacobian once we have that we use
the Jacobian to estimate the gradient
and then the gradient will be used to
take a gradient step and there's the
whole garden
so so in general for further theory it
could be any distribution web server or
random matrices almost any distribution
there's very weak assumptions that we
have and we get a rate for any
distribution but many distribution will
just lead to impractical algorithms so
the practical algorithms will be very
small subset of all of this a huge class
of algorithms and one possibility is
just doing this okay just one vector so
and the super sparse okay or you can
have maybe not one column of the
identity matrix but a random sub matrix
column sub matrix of the identities
there's another option if I pick an AI
then I'm just computing this and is the
green of just a single function I'll
describe it so so this is something that
I'm going to describe yeah okay trigger
so this this this the idea so so
different way of saying this is the
following we want to solve this equation
this is a matrix equation where this is
the left hand side unknown J and this is
the right hand side the true Jacobian if
we knew how to solve this easily we can
just take the J which is this multiplied
by the vector of all ones divided by N
and we get a gradient everything is fine
okay we have no issue so this is one of
the simplest possible linear systems in
a matrix space because the operator is a
identity here okay you don't have to
convert anything the problem here even
though this is a super simple system
it's difficult to solve because you need
to compute every single gradient you
have to compute the right-hand side
first to solve this and this is exactly
what you want to avoid you want to
compute all of these stochastic
gradients and of them because it's
billion of them okay so we have a super
simple inner system which we don't want
to solve ok so what do we do well we do
something much much like so there's the
idea something like a randomized catch
march step but just one step
the generalized randomize catch much
step and this is something which we call
sketch and project so what we do we
multiply the system from the right by
random matrix now it can be anything as
I said and then this is what we measure
so it has to be random matrix where we
are willing to compute this action of
the Jacobian on this random matrix so of
course if you want this to be practical
then this has to be something very
special but but for the theory it could
be anything and then we solve for J now
this will have an infinity of solutions
this as just a single solutions will
have it in resources so how do you pick
from this infinity of solutions
well we build a learning process into
this so what we do just like randomized
Koch March we take the previous estimate
of J and we project it onto the solution
space of this and that's going to be the
new estimate this bit that's that's the
whole idea
so what we do we sample this thing and
particularly
JK which we build throughout the process
and this is the sketched linear system
and is the projection so if you look at
the same thing but not in a matrix set
up in in standard leaner assist systems
set up and this SK is just the ithe unit
coordinate vector this would be the
randomized coach much method this would
be Frobenius norm it'd be some weighted
for being Islam in general but hey I'm
choosing non-weighted Frobenius now okay
so that's it we call this step sketch
and project because you sketch the
system and you project onto it and of
course by doing this one step we have
not solved the original system we have
not done it but we've taken one step of
a randomized method towards solving the
system but then we take the optimization
step now the Jacobian changes and then
we take the randomizing a co-manager a
step and we'll alternate these hopefully
these JK's will converge to the true
Jacobian at the optimal and they will
and hopefully the optimization problem
will be solved at the same time so we're
solving in algebra and optimization for
me
same time in fact the Lyapunov function
that will go to zero is a combination of
the two okay so that's it so this has an
explicit solution can be written down in
this way this is the previous estimator
plus the difference of the previous
estimator and the true Jacobian times
certain projection matrix this
projection onto the range space of SK so
so for now for the theory it can be
anything and this is in fact where many
open problems
now are still are because we didn't go
and exploit this could be many sketching
matrices could be used here and maybe
better rates could be obtained so what
we've done we've just written down the
generic formula for for any distribution
and then we look at the few special
cases and that's it and not even very
elaborate special cases so and if you
want this to be practical then yes think
the best example the thing of its thing
of SK and the random column sub matrix
of the identity matrix with just few
columns that this is this would lead to
something which is called a mini-batch
saga method and this is a very practical
method which has the same performance as
any of the state-of-the-art variants
reduced methods so this is the whole
Jacobean learning step and now we use
the Jacobian to estimate the gradient
okay so how do we do that actually maybe
I should say something about sketching
project so we're working on these
Quechan project iterations for a while
and i'm thinks similar to this and we
written a bunch of paper starting with
with this paper with Robert randomized
iterative methods for linear systems
then we look at the duality behind this
then we looked at application to quasi
Newton methods and matrix inversion in
look of applications to machine learning
and so and so forth one of the last
things for instance that we looked at
was coming up with formula for
accelerate quasi Newton updates for
matrix inversion and so on so there's
lots of interesting things that can be
done with these types of iterations one
can generalize
linear feasibility convex feasibility in
tight way and so on so I don't want to
go there if anybody's interested I'm
happy to talk about this later on all
right so now that we have the JK we have
to use it we want to use it to estimate
the gradient and this is how we're going
to do it so forget about this part
imagine that theta is just 0 actually 1
okay theta is 1 so this is not there and
then what happens is that you just
multiply the Jacobian the latest one
that you have by the vector of all ones
divided by n if this was the true
Jacobian then this would be the true
gradient and everything is perfect ok
now why do we have this convex
combination of the previous estimate
estimate and the new one this is because
we want the estimator GK to be unbiased
estimator of the gradient it turns out
we have to do it this way if you didn't
do it this way if theta was 1 then the
algorithm would be equivalent so that
you get out of this for very special
sketching matrices SK to the ssag method
stochastic average gradient which uses
biased estimator of the grade and this
is notoriously difficult to analyze ok
so it turns out once you plug this
formula for JK plus 1 that I had on one
of these previous slides into this this
is what you get and now what is what so
so you can very easily see the in fact
this is unbiased estimator of the
gradient how well take an expectation of
this where's the randomization it's only
in SK so adjusting these two things
so now by linearity you can go all the
way here and compute the expectation of
this and we will assume about this that
the expectation of this is the vector of
all ones so II there's going to be an
assumption once you have that you're
gonna eat here this part cancels out
with this and you just get this
multiplied by e dy n which is the exact
gradient so you can unbiased estimator
of the gradient so we call this
condition bias correction and that we
call this data escape bias correcting
random variable if it has this property
and there always exists something like
that of course it will depend on the
distribution and so on okay
so that's the idea and then use the GK
to do exactly what I said it on the
first slide just take this great
in step so that's the whole algorithm
and I'll pause for a moment yeah so did
it the choice that's theta or theta yeah
definitely yeah so it's a random
variable depending on SK right so
fastest if you do this SGD stuff where
you choose one data point uniformly at
random then theta would be one over the
probability so be Emma so in fact this
will not be convex combination but it'd
be a combination okay if you choose one
I with roll epi then the Stata will be
one over P I for instance yeah all right
so now this is all I have to say about
this connection to randomize MacLean
lineage abre now I'll give a completely
different but equivalent development of
this algorithm motivation behind this on
what's going on from a different point
of view and we call this the stochastic
reformulation point of view and the idea
is this we started with this
deterministic problem of erm of just
minimize of just average of functions
and we inject randomness into it so we
complicate our lives we start with
something very simple there's not
non-random is there and we make it into
a stochastic optimization problem okay
how do we do it well we first use the
lifting step right here and we take in
the product between this and the vector
of all ones then we use the bias
correction step where we write e as an
expectation so we just write back of all
ones as a mean of some random vectors
okay then we use linearity of
expectation right here we get it out and
now suddenly we have these inner
functions which we can call FS and we
say ok we have a stochastic optimization
problem minimize this expectation this
is completely count to minimizing F but
stochastic gradient applied to this
problem will be something else and
stochastic gradient applied to that one
because not will depend on our choice of
distribution and we can play with it
okay so this is the original problem
this is the new problem for any
distribution is equivalent
okay so that's the first step if you
applied as unique to this what special
cases do we get just to get our
intuition right so if this distribution
is just identity we'll probably one okay
so it's deterministic then it turns out
the biased working random variable
should be one and you get great instant
as a special case so SGD is great in the
sent for special distribution now if you
choose single stochastic you in your
holy api then you get SGD but with known
infant probabilities if you now use okay
you cannot see this but if you use s to
be sum of vectors AI for a random
collection of ice then what you get is a
non in from mini batch as you do okay so
these are all special cases of this SGD
for the stochastic reformulation okay so
this the first point but if we did this
the method will not be very introduced
so this would still be problematic so we
have to throw in an additional trick so
the additional trick is something we
call controlled stochastic reformulation
so we want to inject into the
reformulation our knowledge about the
estimate of the Jacobian in order to
correct for something to make this
reformulation better okay in you will
you can think of this as preconditioning
because we change will change the
reformulation at every iteration using
the JK so that it will have a better
condition number but we do this at every
single iteration of the algorithm so
this will be adaptive stochastic
reconditioning that's that that's
happening here so we change the function
in this way we also inject the blue
stuff the J and if this was not there
this is the original stochastic
formulation but with this we're adding a
zero on average to this so this is a
random variable okay but the expectation
by design is zero so just adding zero to
the function but in a very structured
way and in particular this function zs
has the same form as FS exactly the same
form except wherever we have this
non-linearity FX we put in a linear term
with the Jacobian in
okay so it's a very similar structure
okay so this is also you can think of
this as a control variant which evolves
throughout the iterative process and now
we'll apply SGD to this new control
stochastically formulation and this is
the jack sketch algorithm so the same
algorithm before so this is the jacket
algorithm okay so I'll post again in
case there's any questions so that
stochastic or formulation was exactly of
jian-yang hat in the context of LP
regression he didn't look at the
variance reduction but he had exactly
that in the context so we can follow you
know that may have been off easy to
learn okay so some insight into why this
is variance reduced so here's the
insight we have this theorem which says
that the variance of this estimator
because the unbiased is the variance is
equal equal to this for some very
specific matrix be defined in this way
okay don't look into the details what B
is but it depends on the on the s and so
on okay on the distribution etc so now
you can see how can you make this whole
variance small well either by choosing
the distribution T in such a way that B
is small okay or by trying to learn the
J so that it's close to the Jacobian
there's two ways okay and what we do
what mini batching does it only touches
B what's important sampling does it only
affects be okay but what Jacobian
sketching does it effects J okay but we
can combine mini batching important
sampling and Jacobian sketching at the
same time so we can work with V and J at
the same time okay so this is the
intuition I'll skip this you can give
more insight into this when you upper
bound in and so on but I'll just for the
sake of the time I want to go there and
now I'll go into some special cases
so first special case this is the JAXA
jogger and first of all just reading on
one slide explicitly there's a whole
thing so Jacobian sketching step
estimator of the gradient gradient step
that's it so the special case of jack
sketchy to the saga I'll Gordon
published nips 2004
Dean and the saga algorithm uses this
very particular sketch so just random
count sub matrix of the identity matrix
super sparse so everything is easy to do
so then when you write down the jack
sketch algorithm which is equivalent to
mini batch saga ah Gordon it looks like
just this so all that's going on is that
you maintain these matrices jacobians
where every time you compute the
stochastic gradient belonging to some
random set mini batch that you chosen
you just replace the common by the
stochastic gradient so the Jacobian
estimator always contains in the I've
column the latest stochastic gradient a
data point either you have ever computed
that's it okay so it's very very simple
and then the grade estimator has this
very simple form and you take a great
innocence step so that's it so what can
we say about the iteration complexity of
just catch and then I come back and
compare against what is known about this
particular algorithm so we have this one
general theorem which covers any
sampling any sketching and the general
theorem says that if the number of
iterations at least this constant times
log on of epsilon which means you get
linear rate or exponential decay of the
error then certainly up on a function
will go to below epsilon that we all
know function as I said contains X K so
this is the distance to the minimizer
and also JK - the true Jacobi near the
optimum so it solves the linear system
it's all for the Jacobian and for the
solution at the same time so it truly
solving both of these problems in fact
you can see this as a combination of two
SGD algorithms because this sketchin
project step can be seen as the
application or SGD to a different
stochastic reformulation of the linear
system in the matrix space and this is
of course SGD for the control stochastic
Reformation this is a interplay of two
sgds on two different problems which are
connected and now these constants they
all have some definitions but I don't
want to go there this which is way too
too much to go into the definition of L
1 l 2 mu is strong convexity
okay that's easy and but this Kappa and
Rho and L 1 l 2 these are some novel
constants which also depend on the
randomization and they have not entirely
simple definitions but
to illustrate what this result would
mean I would go into some special cases
so one special case would be great in
the sent okay so if you if you apply
this theorem to the special distribution
we do identity probably one you get we
in the same and this is the way that you
get which is exactly the rate of grading
ascent okay you have a Ford they're
capable we're not worried about that so
so you get the Greenes and almost
perfectly okay so what if you apply saga
with uniform sampling then you get this
and this rate n plus essentially
condition number which is also the known
rate of saga for uniform sampling okay
saga has two here and two here so it's
live variation but this is roughly the
same thing so here there's no surprise
we're not improving anything which is
checking the okay we get in these
special cases what is already known okay
let's try to improve something now so if
you now use mini batch saga then you get
this rate and I'm not going to break it
down into what's going on how is the
mini batch size but what I want to say
is that this improves on the best known
rate from anybody saga in this and it's
2015 paper by Hoffman and Carter's so
while we have this very generic point of
view which works for any sampling and is
sketching for the special sketching we
can improve best known results now we
have also specialized theorem which we
apply to partition sketches so this is a
partition of all these data points and
we select one partition with some money
from probability P CJ okay and then we
use sketch matrix which is the random
cone sub matrix of the identity then
what we get is a specialized theorem and
this theorem gives you tight results for
important sampling for this we had to
develop a new technique with a
stochastic Lyapunov function I'm not
going to the details but there's
something random about this Lyapunov
function which is not just because of JK
and XK okay this is an additional
randomness and then when you apply this
theorem then you get the best known
results resolving a conjecture of Mark
Schmidt and n colors in this paper a I
started in 15 where they said the saga
of an important sampling really should
have this kind of rate but nobody was
able to establish
we get it as a special case okay okay so
finally here the complexity results in
the paper I talk about the some of them
I will go there and just illustrate some
experiments so if we look at regression
and we apply our method this is the saga
with uniform sampling this is the saga
with the best-known important sampling
up to now the paper that I mentioned and
there's the saga with our important
sampling which which which is much
better than than the business I go with
important sampling so this is one
example another example is only best
leave SVM data set where we apply mini
batch saga this was the best known mini
batch saga performance this is our mini
bridge circuit performance
okay so let's forget about what these
things mean but the point is as the mini
batch size increases the gap also
increases and finally if you apply
logistically regression and compared to
some other methods such as SVR gene
let's say Serg is right here our method
is right here and these are the two
variants of our method one is the one
which uses unbiased estimator which is
the saga and the one the red one uses an
unbiased estimator so this is the
stochastic average green estimator for
some reason this almost always
outperforms the unbiased one but nobody
knows why okay that's roughly it thank
you very much
[Applause]
why don't we have a quick question why
do you want to get set up and maybe
professional we get time good setup okay
also can you comment on the body pocket
I'm sorry show cover is faster with the
ponies so you have the rates are faster
but are you paying a lot for inflation
compared to estimate so there we were
we're not comparing through iterations
the excesses were not iterations
these were passes through data so
whenever we are preparing against other
algorithms the the one iteration is
really the same cost we're not comparing
on comparable things of course no no you
can so the the tests were set up in such
a way that these steps are very
comparable almost identical we just
compute one or a subset of stochastic
gradient and there's the main cost
because of the variance reduction right
but what I'm saying is what is the party
pop cost like so caustic redness is like
a coin flip yes
so this is the cost here is roughly
twice update of iterations goes down my
no decrease is much much more if you
look at the special case you need to be
roughly like that in the special case in
general it could be you know very bad
but in the special case is super cheap
and we can can take it off when I can
show you why okay thank you